if the brain is a muscle and trying
harder can lead to better learning does
that mean that anyone can be Salkin
anyone can be Mark Zuckerberg or is
there something innate about great
entrepreneurs that can't be learned I
don't know the absolute statement here I
do think that most people on the planet
are capable of mastering calculus are
capable of programming a computer are
capable of understanding genetics or
quantum physics I genuinely believe that
I know the example I always give is if
you went 400 years back to Western
Europe you would see that roughly 20% of
men and 10% of women were literate could
read what can anyone start Facebook can
anyone start the Khan Academy I don't
know I don't know for sure I mean some
of these things you know Mark Zuckerberg
with the slightly you know she shift his
life a year forward a year back he might
have not started Facebook he might have
been an engineer at Facebook you shift
Sal Khan's life a year forward a year
back you put him in instead of growing
up in New Orleans if you grew up in
Calcutta I might have you don't know
what paths would have been they are
people who push themselves to grow and
and and and learn new things but they
also had a lot of opportunity they were
in the right places at the right time
and and and you know a little little
dose of luck now it never heard I think
a Mark Zuckerberg would have been
successful in anything that he did I
know if I said everybody could be Mark
Zuckerberg but I think there's a lot of
people who could be Mark Zuckerberg who
right now think that they can't